esta ciudad de slowans en la zona del
Don Baz ha sido atacada intensamente
desde el 24 de febrero Cuando comenzó la
invasión ha tenido decenas de problemas
Además logísticos porque cortaron el
agua durante semanas y este hospital ha
sido el centro de la atención
especialmente de aquella población mayor
que se quedó en la ciudad y a cargo del
hospital está Valentina groschenko una
mujer que solamente un mes Antes había
tenido a cargo la dirección de este
centro hospitalario
el frente de batalla estaba 15 km y nos
atacaban con misiles todas las noches
todos los días entonces había muchas más
personas heridas que ahora tanto civiles
como militares que venían a pedirnos
ayuda Pero luego se dio la
contraofensiva desde harky hacia liman y
el cambio en la ciudad ha sido notable
hay muchos menos misiles todo está mucho
más tranquilo
la liberación de zonas cercanas a
estudiantes
presión a la ciudad Diana alejado al
frente de batalla ha traído nuevos retos
el primero que mayor población
especialmente mayor ha regresado a la
ciudad y segundo atienden más personas
que vienen de pueblos que por meses
estuvieron en control de las tropas
rusas y que no tuvieron atención médica
Desde que la situación se ha calmado ha
habido muchos más casos pacientes con
paros cardíacos también nos traen Muchos
pacientes con infartos con diferentes
traumas muchos de ellos vienen con
costillas rotas de tiempo atrás a las
que no se les había prestado atención
también hay muchos casos de peritonitis
porque la gente estaba encerrada en los
sótanos por mucho tiempo muchas personas
pasaban cinco o seis días con
peritonitis sin ser atendidas
soy una convencida de que las
instituciones médicas deben seguir
trabajando bajo cualquier circunstancia
estoy muy agradecida con todas las
personas que nos ayudaron en los
momentos más difíciles y en especial a
todos los empleados que no se fueron de
la ciudad en resumen a todos los que
vinieron a ayudarnos ha sido un trabajo
duro muy duro eso es seguro